STEVE BANNON IS ONE OF TRUMP'S
ALLIES, HE HAS ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
HE ADVISED BOLSONARO AS HE WAS
PUSHING THE MISINFORMATION
SURROUNDING THIS ELECTION BACK
IN NOVEMBER.
>> LOCK IN THE STREETS OF
BRAZIL.
LOOK AT THE GREAT PATRIOTS OF
BRAZIL THAT, AT A LOT OF DANGER
TO THEMSELVES, HAVE COME
FORWARD.
IN THE STREETS OF BRAZIL THIS IS
THE PEOPLE SAYING NO, YOU DIDN'T
FOLLOW THE CONSTITUTION.
YOU USED THE MACHINES, THE
JUDICIARY TO SHUT US DOWN IN THE
MEDIA AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
TOLERATE IT.
IT'S GOING TO BE INTERESTING TO
SEE HOW IT PLAYS OUT.
>> WE'RE SEEING HOW IT PLAYS OUT
NOW.
JOHN AVLON IS HERE TO DISCUSS.
IT WASN'T JUST STEVE BANNON
WHO'S BEEN ADVICING HIM.
JASON MILLER WAS PART OF THE
CONVERSATIONS.
BOLSONARO IS IN FLORIDA RIGHT
NOW, WE SHOULD NOTE.
WHAT HAS STOOD OUT TO YOU ABOUT
THE TAKEAWAYS AND THE
SIMILARITIES BETWEEN WHAT
HAPPENED AFTER THE ELECTION AND
NOW WHAT WE'RE SEEING PLAY OUT?
>> THE ECHOS ARE UNMISTAKABLE --
>> IT'S NOT EVEN ECHOS, RIGHT?
>> MARK TWAIN SAID HISTORY
DOESN'T REPEAT BUT SOMETIMES IT
RHYMES.
THIS IS A CLOSE RHYME.
BECAUSE PEOPLE FANNING THE
FLAMES IN THE U.S. ARE THE
TRUMPEST WING OF THE CREW
FANNING THE FLAMES AROUND THE
STOP THE STEAL MOVEMENT, NOT
JUST STEVE BANNON AS YOU SAY.
THERE'S BEEN A MOVE TO DENY THE
LEGITIMACY OF THIS ELECTION FROM
SOME OF TRUMP'S FORMER ADVISERS
SAYING DO NOT CONCEDE.
YOU HAVE A SLIGHTLY DELAYED
REACTION BUT A DIRECT ATTACK ON
THE CAPITAL BY A MOB AND IT
SPEAKS TO THE FACT THAT
DEMOCRACY BEING UNDER ASSAULT IS
NOT OVER.
AND SOME OF THE PEOPLE USING
SOCIAL MEDIA TO ENCOURAGE THESE
SORTS OF MOB ATTACKS ARE SOME OF
THE PEOPLE WHO, FROM THESE
SELF-STYLED POPULIST NATIONAL
MOVEMENT THEY SEEK TO MAKE
NATIONAL.
>> THERE WAS A GREAT PIECE
REPUBLISHED THIS MORNING IN "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" FROM MONTHS AGO
THAT JUST WALKED THROUGH THE
MONTHS AND YEARS OF LIES ABOUT
ELECTION FRAUD THAT BOLSONARO
MADE AND CONTINUES TO MAKE THAT
LED TO THIS, LEAD TO THIS, THE
PARALLELS ARE SO STRIKING WITH
THE MONTHS AND YEARS OF LIES
THAT CONTINUE ON NOW.
THE QUESTION BEYOND WHAT WE SAW
HAPPEN IN BRAZIL.
THOSE LIES FROM THOSE LEADERS
CONTINUE.
>> THAT'S --
>> SO THEN WHAT?
>> I THINK IT'S HIGHLIGHTS THE
FACT THERE IS A STRUGGLE BETWEEN
DISINFORMATION AND DEMOCRACY.
AND DISINFORMATION CAN CREATE
REAL WORLD IMPACTS.
THE ROLE OF BOT TS IN BRAZIL
SPREADING MISINFORMATION BUT
ALSO BEING DONE HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES BY SOME OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CLOSEST
ADV
ADVISERS.
THAT SPEAKS TO THE FACT THAT THE
DISINFORMATION FLOW AROUND THE
WORLD IS INTERNATIONAL.
>> DO YOU REMEMBER BECAUSE WE
LIVED THIS --
>> YES.
>> -- WE ALL LIVED THIS.
PEOPLE WOULD SAY WHY DO YOU KEEP
COVERING JANUARY 6th?
WHY ARE YOU TRYING TO DIVIDE THE
COUNTRY?
NO.
THERE WAS AN ATTACK ON THE
DEMOCRACY, THIS IS IMPORTANT.
THIS SHOULD BE THE LEAD STORY
EVERY NIGHT ON EVERY NEWS
BROADCAST UNTIL PEOPLE REALIZE.
AND THEN HUH THE VOICES ON THE
CONSERVATIVE SIDE OR LACK OF
VOICES, NOT CALLING THIS OUT OR
CRITICIZING THE NEWS MEDIA FOR
REPORTING ON THIS.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
ALLOW AUTHORITARIAN TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR FROM LEADERS.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
ALLOW MISINFORMATION --
>> PROLIFERATE.
>> LOOK I THINK THAT IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
THIS IS A REAL-WORLD IMPACT TWO
YEARS DELAYED IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY.
IT SHOWS THIS IS NOT ACADEMIC.
UNTIL THERE'S ACCOUNTABLE AND WE
GET BETTER COMBATTING
DISINFORMATION CONSISTENT WITH
OUR LIBERAL VALUES NOT ONLY HERE
BUT ABROAD, THESE THINGS WILL
CONTINUE TO CUR.
THE FACT IT'S THE SAME PLAYERS
SPREADING THE SAME
MISINFORMATION AND LIES, HAVING
THE SAME REAL WORLD EFFECT
SHOULD BE THE SAME WAKE UP CALL
TO US ALL.
>> WE'LL SEE WHAT REPUBLICANS
SAY ABOUT THIS.
DEMOCRATS WANT THEM TO WEIGH IN
AND CONDEMN WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
BRAZIL.
ALSO, THE U.S. AMBASSADOR TO
BRAZIL IS GETTING SWORN IN TODAY
AT 3:45.
THANK YOU FOR LAYING OUT WHAT'S
IMPORTANT HERE.
IT HAS GLOBAL IMPACTS.
>> THIS HAS BEEN TOP OF MIND FOR
YOU FOR YEARS FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
THANK YOU, DON.
APPRECIATE IT.
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE IN
BRASILIA RIGHT NOW WHERE TROOPS
ARE LINING UP ACROSS FROM THE
PROTESTERS.
THE DEADLINE TO CLEAR THEM JUST
FOUR HOURS AWAY AFTER THIS
HAPPENED YESTERDAY.
THOSE RIOTERS ARE SUPPORTER OF
FORMER PRESIDENT BOLSONARO,
STORMED AND VANDALIZED BRAZIL'S
CONGRESS, SECURITY FORCES USED
TEAR GAS AND REGAIN CONTROL OF
THE BUILDINGS.
OFFICIALS DECLARING OVERNIGHT
THE RIOTS ARE OVER, AT LEAST 400
PEOPLE ARE UNDER ARREST, IT
COMES A WEEK AFTER PRESIDENT
LULA Da SILVA VOWING TO PUNISH
THOSE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
ATTACKS.
WHAT'S THE SITUATION IN THE
CAPITOL THIS MORNING?
>> Reporter: IT'S UNDER CONTROL
BUT LOOKS LIKE A WAR ZONE.
IMAGINE FOR A MOMENT THAT THE
JANUARY 6th MOB HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES HAD NOT ONLY
BREACHED THE CAPITOL BUT ALSO
THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE SUPREME
COURT BUILDING.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED IN
BRAZIL SUNDAY AN INSURRECTION
THAT ENDED WITH THE ARREST OF AT
LEAST 400 PEOPLE, LEFT THE MAIN
PUBLIC BUILDINGS IN THE COUNTRY
INOPERABLE AND DEEPENED A
POLITICAL CRISIS THAT HAS BEEN
BREWING FOR MONTHS.
BRAZIL BOILING OVER.
SUPPORTERS OF FORMER BRAZILIAN
PRESIDENT BOLSONARO, STORMED KEY
BUILDINGS ON SUNDAY BREACHING
SECURITY BARRIERS AND
TEMPORARILY OCCUPYING THE
COUNTRY'S CONGRESS, PRESIDENTIAL
PALACE, AND SUPREME COURT.
MASSES OF PROTESTERS FLOODED THE
COUNTRY'S SEAT OF POWER, MANY
DRESSED IN THE COLORS OF
BRAZIL'S FLAG, YELLOW AND GREEN,
FUELLED BY ANGER AND DISTRUST
OVER BOLSONARO'S DEFEAT WHERE HE
LOST IN A RUNOFF LAST MONTH TO
LULA Da SILVA.
PROTESTERS THREW OBJECTS WHILE
CLASHING WITH POLICE WHO THREW
TEAR GAS.
CNN REPORTS THE FLOOR OF THE
CONGRESS BUILDING WAS FLOODING
AFTER THE SPRINKLER SYSTEM
ACTIVATED WHEN PROTESTERS TRIED
TO SET FIRE TO THE CARPET.
BY EVENING THE POLICE WERE
ARRESTING HUNDREDS.
PRESIDENT Da SILVA DESCRIBED THE
EVENTS AS BAR BARE RICK AND
VOWED TO PUNISH THE PEOPLE
RESPONSIBLE.
>> Translator: THOSE PEOPLE THAT
WE CALL FASCIST, WE CALL THEM
EVERYTHING ABOMBABLE IN
POLITICS.
THEY INVADED THE GOVERNMENT
HEADQUARTERS, AND THEY INVADED
THE CONGRESS LIKE VANDALS.
DESTROYING EVERYTHING IN THEIR
PATH.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT LULA Da
SILVA ALSO BLAMED HIS
PREDECESSOR FOR THE LACK OF
SECURITY IN THE CAPITOL WHERE
BOLS
BOLSONARO'S SUPPORTERS HAVE BEEN
CAMPING OUT FOR A WEEK.
BOLSONARO SAID PEACEFUL AND
LAWFUL DEMONSTRATIONS ARE PART
OF DEMOCRACY.
BUT CRITICS SAY HE STIRRED UP
THE CROWD BY SAYING HE
QUESTIONED THE INTEGRITY OF THE
COUNTRY'S ELECTRONIC VOTING
SYSTEM.
NEW DETAILS HAVE EMERGED ABOUT
HOW VIOLENT SOME OF THE
PROTESTERS BECAME, AT LEAST 12
JOURNALISTS WERE ATTACKED,
ROBBED OR WILL THEIR EQUIPMENT
DESTROYED.
BACK TO YOU.
>> JUST AN AWFUL THANK YOU.